- Put it right there.
(soft music)
- My lips are like honestly the one thing
that I feel like I don’t
love about my face.
- I feel like growing up I’ve
started to get more and more
critical of how I look.
- I feel like they’re just really thin,
and there’s not much shape to them, like
they’re just kind of like (hums).
- I never really thought
about changing my lips
until I saw all these
images, and was like:
“I wish I looked like that!”
- It’s just like so hot right now
to have really nice puckered up
beautiful lips.
All these women and men are aspiring
to look like these celebrities.
- It does make you want to
change things about yourself.
- I’m Dr. Andre Berger,
and we’re Rejuvalife Vitality Institute
in Beverly Hills, California:
the mecca of aesthetic
medicine and surgery.
We’ve got two really
pretty girls here today
and they would like to just
give a little more enhancement
to their already beautiful lips.
- Is there gonna be like a
side-angle difference afterwards?
- [Nurse] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Really?
- [Nurse] Yeah!
- Oh my god! (giggling)
- So you have great lips,
you’d like greater lips?
- Yeah, I want them to be bigger.
- Okay, so what we have to do is
we want to give you more volume, but we
want to match your face, too.
So what we’re gonna try and do
is give you a really pretty enhancement,
but you already have pretty lips.
We’re just gonna try and make
‘em a little more pretty.
- Me on the other hand! (laughs)
- You’re a slightly different situation.
- My lips aren’t quite as nice as Ella’s.
- [Dr] No, your lips
are equally beautiful.
- Oh, well thank you.
- In your case however, the difference is
your philtrum is kind
of a little bit flat.
So we want to enhance the cupid’s bow
and give you a little more of a philtrum.
It’ll just kind of bring that
lip up a little bit, alright?
- Is it dangerous at all to do this?
- Not if I do it.
- I’m excited!
- Yeah, I’m really excited!
(overlapping chatter)
- It’s contagious!
- I’m really nervous.
I’m nervous for the procedure,
like needles scare me
a little bit.
- I mean,
I’m a little nervous
for them to fuck it up,
to be honest.
It’s weird to put your
trust in someone else
for your face.
(soft music)
I’m freaking out!
I literally can’t believe
this is real life right now.
(voice soft and indistinct under music)
Okay!
Honestly, like even though
we had a consultation,
I feel like I don’t know
what’s gonna actually happen
like right now.
- We were joking about
it for a few months, like
“Oh yeah, wouldn’t that be so funny
“if we got lip injections?”
- And now it’s like the
moment is literally here.
Right now!
- [Ella] Yeah.
What if they’re never the same?
Like what if they’re never the same again?
Oh my god, you guys.
(laughing)
- [Dr] She’s praying.
That’s a prayer, you see that?
You pray for more beautiful lips.
I’m gonna put a little numbing stuff
inside the gum here,
before I inject anything.
- Okay.
- [Dr] Okay, now I’m gonna
inject a little numbing medicine.
(soft music)
How’s that feel?
- It’s okay.
- [Dr] Okay?
- [Ella] Very numb.
Oh god, it’s so numb.
Oh my god!
- [Voiceover] Can you talk?
- Now we’re numb, so we’re gonna inject.
- Okay.
- So I want to put, put it right there.
(instrumental music)
- Is it done?
- [Dr] It’s done!
- Oh my gosh!
- That feels very odd.
- I’m like scared to look.
Like I obviously want to see, I’m just...
- [Dr] Smile.
(laughs)
- Wow yeah, it’s a lot different.
- I’m overwhelmed right now.
- [Dr] Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- We’ll put some ice on you now.
- Okay.
- [Dr] Didn’t hurt, did it?
- No, it didn’t hurt.
- There you go, beautiful lips, no pain.
(laughing)
- This is just the
weirdest thing like ever.
- I can’t believe we actually did that.
I feel so weird.
- It feels so weird!
- I can’t feel my face at all.
- So it’s about 10 o’clock at night,
and I’m laying in my bed,
and...
It’s like really sore.
- I can kind of feel on the inside, like,
it feels kind of swollen.
- I’m like damn, was this really worth
how I feel right now?
- My opinion of lip injections
has definitely changed
over the course of this last week.
One thing I hadn’t considered beforehand
was that it would actually hurt,
and I would actually be in
physical pain afterwards.
- I thought going into it
that it was just gonna be like
couple needles there,
then you’re done and then
you have nice, plump lips.
But it was actually like this whole thing.
- Now I know that it’s a lot more serious,
and it’s not something that
you should take lightly.
- After they numbed my lips,
I had this moment where
I was just sitting there
and I thought, “What did I
“get myself into?”
- We talk about celebrities,
like, “Oh, she got
“her lips done,” and we
don’t really talk about
the fact that they’re actual people
and they actually had to go
into the doctor’s office,
get needles in their face...
- I probably wouldn’t do
it again, just because
the whole thing was so involved.
- I feel like I’m really
50/50 on if I would or not.
I actually like it, and I’m
getting more used to it,
but also knowing all of the
things that go into getting it.
- I think overall we’re just too critical.
- Everyone has really great lips!
I definitely have a new appreciation for
my old lips.
I don’t think that they were
as bad as I thought they were.
- If you want to make a
change it has to be because
you want it, not because
of what other people
are gonna say or think about it.
(soft music)